I mean it's kind of like The Sisterhood
of traveling wigs baby I'm gonna untuck
these secrets with you okay my name is
Blair [ __ ] came from me binge watching
Gossip Girl and the Blair Witch Project
at the time I was living on the Upper
East Side so I was like I'm the queen
bee of the Upper East Side I'm freaky
and no one actually knows what I look
like Blair [ __ ] my name is Jan spoor
and I've been doing drag for two years
I like JanSport because not only do I
think it's funny and people will get the
reference but I grew up playing sports
all my life so I might be a drag queen
but like I love to go watch football
with my dad I'd love to go to hockey
game I played soccer for 14 years I
wanted to become a drag queen because I
went to school for musical theater and
then I didn't get a job after so I
thought drag queen
my experience with tucking is bleak
I like to think of what I do more is
like cramming or like smashing we refer
to it as the Monster Mash in the
business you just kind of just like and
it's probably my least favorite part of
drag but let me tell you once you do it
a few times it's nothing and I don't
think that you have to tuck to be a drag
queen there's so much androgyny in the
field of drag now that I live for and I
love to do myself to hurt so like you
need to Free Willy them Free Willy yeah
now this men are not the only people who
could be a drag queen I know drag queens
who identify out of drag as gender
non-binary as trans every single person
on this planet can do drag it's all
about gender expression it started as
men dressing up as women so then to tell
the women that they can't dress up as
the women is redundant and pointless
because it's an art form there's room
for everyone and any queen that does not
think that's true needs to stand down it
costs a lot of money to look at this
expensive okay I would say that from
head to toe right now I'm in at least
$1,500
easily the price of a small child if you
like some mountains how much money I've
spent I try to give a number but I'm
horrible at math and it would bring me
to tears I spend a lot on makeup hair
costumes nails but I probably spend the
most on my hair I feel like it's the
first thing that people see and it's
instantly recognizable I'm a proud wig
addict and I'm probably not gonna stop
it's expensive if you really want to
invest in it if you're not trying to
invest in it and you just want to have
fun you want to do it on Halloween you
want to go do a number at a show it
doesn't take that much to do oh I have
maybe a cup and drag maybe I don't like
nothing up my lip there's just too much
that's going on here I spent way too
much time on this like I don't want to
do that there is those men's that like
they just they want they want the balls
now the girls the girls you know what I
mean
so my drag is hyper feminine so I like
to pad but I mean padding is another
personal thing that you can do or choose
to not do if I wear full-on like foam
hip pads I look like an eggplant emoji
it's not you so I went to a good old
Raymour and Flanigan this is Ray more
this is Flanagan you take a turkey
Carver and you carve out a shape kind of
like a teardrop and you get this lovely
shape to all just because you think that
my butt is foam-padded does not mean you
get to touch it so respect it really
doesn't take me long at all like today
it took me about five minutes I just
rolled out of bed and here for me it
takes me about an hour and a half to get
ready with hair body face as we like to
say it can easily take me four hours I
have been known to spins but in seven
hours on the face I don't have any
apologies except for all of the gigs
I've been late to I'm sorry and booked
me again
rule number one in a drag queen arena if
you see something you like tip something
if you see something you love tip them
white tip drag queens always if you go
to a drug show have ones have fives have
tens have twenties
if you give me a fifty like you your
requests will come true
you should always tip a drag queen
especially if you're at a show at a bar
for free the least you can do is give a
dollar if you're enjoying the
performance of five if you really really
liked and resonated with what somebody
was doing a twenty if you have a request
for a song that you know that they want
to do and and a hundred if you are so
blown away that you just want me to
leave because I will leave for a hundred
dollars have you ever wanted to know
what it was like behind the scenes at a
drag competition it's really not all
that we're just like probably hugging
and doing each other's makeup I mean
it's kind of like The Sisterhood of
traveling wigs you know I think that
drag queens have the reputation of being
really catty and being very harsh to
each other but I found in my own
experiences that drag is really really
welcoming I think that you have to go
out and get the respect of the Queens
who came before you I became their
friends and they would help me when I
had any questions I wish that people
knew that drug is more than just like
fun crazy people in crazy wigs it's such
hard work you have to make a lot of
sacrifices to be attracting when I'm
singing that's something that I trained
for for my entire life that takes years
of practice and hours of cultivating
numbers and getting material for that I
don't think that people really see all
the hours and the time that it takes
it's so many different art forms that
you have to master you have to be on all
the time
we're neglected a lot of times as
performers give us the time of day don't
doubt what I can do performance wise
just because I'm a pretty girl
are there any baby drag queens out there
watching if so don't be afraid come up
to us ask us all the questions
you want don't ask me if you can do drag
ask me how you can do drag the
possibilities are endless if you have an
interest try it you might love it I'm a
drag queen because I need to do drag
it's my back I hope that I spilled all
the secrets and served you the tea that
you were looking for you have any crazy
drag stories just comment below let us
know I'm gonna read them I'll probably
perform one of them at one of my next
show so please let me know what you did
[Music]
you